[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
back this time is 7:30 no wait that's
not the time its tactics time all right
my name is national master caleb Denby
and today I wanted to warm you guys up
with some tactics that you might have
not been expecting and then we're gonna
switch back over to some real chests get
some nice chest puzzles in there for you
see what you guys can do but to start
off with I'm gonna show you this
position that I have on the board here
this is a pretty strange looking one and
you might think that black is simply
winning here because black is up a piece
that is until you're told this is not
real chess this is atomic chess so of
course
atomic chess is a pretty interesting
variant where whenever pieces are
captured
for example if pawn takes pawn were to
be played the pawns at the puns that are
directly involved with captures actually
explode and the pieces in the
surrounding square explode as well with
the exception of other pawns so just to
kind of show you some of the rules here
for example if this bishop we're here
and this pawn were captured this bishop
is in the square so the bishop would
explode
now you don't win this game by checkmate
although you can this game is won by
blowing up the King so if the King finds
itself within the square when a piece is
captured then the game is over
so with that in mind those of you who
already know the rules to atomic
probably have a leg up here but this
position is actually black to move and
win there's only one winning move and
I'd be interested to see if you guys can
find it knowing these rules of atomic
chess I'll give you a hint or two since
this is not real chess you may have not
been ready for it if if of course you
know this came first of all it cannot
capture this pawn it's illegal because
the King would explode if you promote to
a queen in this variant you more or less
win the game so that's going to be
similar to real chess the question is
can you find out how to force a
promotion here for black how can you
force promotion
what do you guys think I'll leave it to
you from there this is the the crux of
this atomic puzzle is train of force
promotion and while you're thinking
about it I do want to mention that's you
know variant tactics are a pretty unique
thing they're pretty strange and it's
pretty tough to find them that is until
a very nice website came out but I will
tell you the name of chess variants and
dot training that's where I got these
puzzles and it's where you can do some
more chess variant training all on your
own completely for free
I believe it runs off of Lee chess and
most of the tactics are taken from
variant games only chess okay I'm seeing
two illegal moves in the chat so far so
that's not the answer this should be
three I don't even know what you
intended to say oh maybe you meant
bishop g6 okay you'll have to tell me
your idea with bishop g6 and then the
the move b6 was suggested I don't know
what you mean by that one actually b6
the pawns are traveling in the opposite
direction so legal moves it's legal
moves so Bishop g6 I'm gonna assume he
meant what's the idea
with Bishop g6 hello is Austin's a
sympton so soon to Myanmar I don't know
if I can pronounce that I tried
once again atomic chess there any ideas
okay Alec harsh
I appreciate you appreciate you
rephrasing as bishop g6 but what's your
idea
what's the idea with bishop g6 i won't
settle for just the first move i won't
settle
okay been saying a or for in this these
t-shirts t s-- is playing before so i
will say i think your idea with bishop
g6 if i'm if i'm not mistaken is that
after any move you want to capture here
and i think your idea is to start
pushing this pawn and this wouldn't be a
horrible idea if it didn't lose by force
of course white can simply blockade
you're a pawn and now no matter what you
play white is actually the one who will
end up cleaning with check and of course
that is going to be enough to win this
game for white so you do have to be a
little bit careful about well what
passed pawn you make remember you can
never capture this age pond because it
explodes your own king explodes your own
king okay Matisse wants to play a four
but b4 is gaining in popularity as well
b4 is gaining in popularity so let's
take a look at a four a four he says you
force a pawn trade and this is true this
is a true story you do force upon trade
however let me ask you to the question
how are you replying to b4 how do you
reply to b4 here because this one is
going to cause you some pretty serious
consternation i'm not mistaken so of
course the only way to try to win this
game is to try to make a passed pawn so
if you try to make a passed pawn well
why it's gonna take this one now the
only pawn you can capture anymore is
going to be this pawn on e4 and what's
going to be ready to placate this pawn
no matter what you're doing and if you
take the other way
well of course white can also capture
the other way and you get the same
position so a4 I think b4 is going to be
enough for white to hold
and a similar problem kind of occurs if
you play the move be for let's see here
before let's try and calculate what can
white do
what can we do wait to move and save the
game
wait to move and save the game yeah
hello hello to Colby
congratulations on catching it life
bishop f2 is nowhere near being a legal
move I owe you do me in bed sure about
7:00 Bishop f7 okay so you want fish
about seven in the initial position so
we're looking at b4 though and it turns
out actually I don't think the chats
gonna get this one
a4 is really just going to be enough to
save the game if you sacrifice this
bishop well congratulations you
sacrificed your bishop
but for what but for what actually a4 is
not gonna be it we have to take this
pawn and now if you play a four of
course this is going to be another drop
because you cannot sacrifice this bishop
or else you lose and if you play Bishop
a4 trying to be clever
well white can simply just in time run
his King to this Queen side of the board
and uh-oh it's black to move now can't
move any pawns have to move the King and
white will Queen and win so cautious
cautious play is required so not before
is your your jacoco I'm gonna go with
Jacobo hello to Jimmy as well says
Bishop f7 well Bishop f7 you're running
into the same problem here guys White's
going to run the King over and blockade
whatever passed pawn you make and then
you're gonna be the one in trouble cuz
you have to move out of the way this
pawn it's just going to run this King
over unless you do something about it
so Wow tough start to tactics time here
I didn't think you guys would struggle
quite so much with this one although it
is pretty tricky now that we're getting
into some lines here so I might just
have to give you guys the answer to this
no one has even suggested the correct
first move yet that this isn't there's
only so many first moves no one has
found the correct first move why doesn't
the king take the pawn good question we
have are of course talking about atomic
chests here this is atomic chess and
whichever piece and gets captured all
the pieces in the surroundings square
explode including the king
so Kings actually can't capture anything
in this variant then it's Bishop move
Bishop g6 of course the correct move is
not Bishop g6 not Bishop f7 not before
not a four it is B takes c4 of course
this is the winning move for black the
idea is you yes you need to make a
passed pawn but you also want to
preserve your bishop while you do it
you don't want to sacrifice this bishop
needlessly otherwise you're going to be
in pretty serious trouble
so now if white simply brings the King
over what do we do when we make a passed
pawn but we do so with the move a4 now
White has no way to prevent the C pawn
from moving forward if you take here
well we can start pushing and just to
examine it let's say let's see what
happens
c2 can you see one now we move this
bishop or we can simply take here and
now with white to move it is black
who is queening in winning the game
perhaps a little bit trickier for white
is not splitting you to try this move
a4 but now the idea is we do have to
sacrifice the bishop but we do so in the
most favorable favorable way possible
with this pawn being all the way on the
a file and now the rule is a little bit
different in atomic chess yes white can
step into the square of the pawn but
since the King cannot actually capture
it's still too far away
and if we look we see devastatingly
Blackwell Queen and when this atomic
chess game so an interesting tactic
there for you atomic chest fans
unfortunately no one got it in in the
YouTube chat I know it's a little bit
tough you have to really change your
brain change your way of thinking here
and the main reason well the main thing
you have to do with that regard in an
atomic chess is realized
whenever you capture a piece that's it
your piece goes off the board as well
and pawns they cannot really be captured
by Kings nothing can really be captured
by Kings the Kings are worthless
ok good attempts though on that puzzle
you guys did come up with some creative
ideas of course in this endgame and
actually a ton games in real chess you
always want to look to make the past
pawn as far away from the Kings as
possible and you don't want to sacrifice
your material until you absolutely have
to those are the principles and real
chess that actually could have helped
you to solve this puzzle all right that
one took a while so we're only gonna do
one or two more of these variant tactics
and then we'll switch on over to real
chess so now do you guys want to do
crazy variants or a little bit more
normal variants your call crazy rants or
more normal variants try to figure out
using normal rules yet so hopefully
you've got the gist now we're doing
variant tactics to start with all right
I'm just gonna do more crazy variants
because what's the point of doing normal
variants this variance is a pretty good
one this one might be one you're not
familiar with it's a little bit
lesser-known this variant is racing
Kings who doesn't love scoring
touchdowns and now that football got
cancelled you can do it in your chess
games of course the idea of the Racing
Kings variant is the first person to get
to the back ranked wins the game
now white obviously has a little bit of
an advantage in this race as he moves
first so there is a special rule in
place where just to show you if white
moves to the back rank first black then
has a turn to get to the back rank as
well and if this happens the game is
declared
you know they they tie it in the race
however if black is the first one to
move to the back rank since he moves
second in the game he wins automatically
so let me introduce to you now this
tactic that we have here there's one
more sorry one more key rule to racing
Kings that makes it really abnormal you
cannot legally legally check the king
I'm gonna say that again
it's illegal to give check I hear our
producers going crazy Tracy out there is
so angry you can't check the king it's
legal look I'm gonna try check check it
won't let me and won't let me do it you
can't check the king it's illegal so
check and checkmate illegal you can only
win the game by getting that King to the
back rank of course though it is still
illegal to move your king to a square
where it would be attacked so right now
we see white is successfully preventing
black from getting to the back rank so
this tactic is gonna revolve around
black forcing his way onto the back rank
one way or another so let's see if you
can find it let's see if you can find it
get the King to the back row win the
race score a touchdown score a touchdown
everybody you got to get there one way
or another
so key rules to keep in mind you only
win by getting the back rank check is
illegal in black wins the second he
touches that back row so that's the
that's the idea black to move get to the
back rank
I think Bensimon has the answer or
perhaps Tracy one of them been of course
suggested the correct move Knight f3
that's Tracy Tracy solving the racing
Kings tactic from the main area she's
too strong Knight f3 is in fact the move
what does this move do it does a few
things one it hangs the knight but
that's not the point the point is it's
interfering with this bishops control of
the a8 square that's what racing Kings
is all about getting that King up the
board one rank at a time since check is
illegal once you go up a rank Ian never
really have to go back down one unless
you choose to so Knight f3 interferes
with the bishop so now what can we do
about this well he has to guard the a8
Square somehow and with check being
illegal these moves are not gonna do it
Queen B it's not going to do it there's
only one way to continue guarding the a8
square and that's to take back with the
bishop now of course the obvious problem
with this rook takes Queen and now it's
the BH square that's the trouble and
there's no way for white to legally
guard b8 of course 96 is illegal as it
gives check and check is illegal now of
course if you take the knight with the
knight well you gave up the a at the
square and black would win so there you
go little racing Kings tactic for you
hopefully enjoyed that one I saw someone
mentioned three check don't worry I've
got three check tactics too I've got
three check tactics all day long welcome
to a three check tactic it is black to
move here important information for this
one in the game that this was taken from
Black has already given two checks in
this position so one more check in black
wins the game light in the meanwhile has
given zero checks so zero to two in
blacks favor one more check wins for
black white has to give three more
checks to win the game
that's the variant of three check of
course if you give three check game ends
you win so what can black play here to
take advantage of the fact that only one
more check is required for him to win
what can he do you know and I might
change my mind I'm having so much fun
maybe we'll just do varying tactics the
whole time I do have some real tactics
just in case you guys get a little bit
bored who knows who knows how to give
that third check that's always the
problem with this variant I've played
many many three check games where I
sacrifice all my pieces I get two checks
but then you just can't get a third one
Jonathan Harper has an interesting idea
Jonathan Harper says Queen f5 what's the
threat with Queen f5 what is black
threatening and then how can white step
out of it
what's the threat the line doesn't end
after Queen f5 got to keep going
at ease is confused understandably it's
confusing life is confusing okay we're
getting a myriad of illegal moves once
again I don't understand
f6 is legal but it might as well be
illegal because that's how much I don't
understand it
okay I guess I understand f6 so the
point of f6 is you're trying to get this
bishop to move when you can give Queen G
to winning the game but unfortunately
white does not have to move this Bishop
you can even take on d6 instead ah there
you go
the chats finally caught up with me
Queen f5 is the correct first move it
threatens Queen takes h3 winning the
game with the third check now there's
only one way to really step out of this
for white I mean you could play Knight
h2 but this is going to be checkmate so
King g1 is the only reasonable move and
now how do you continue with black only
one way to win this game only one way to
win King g1 is a very nice try by by
white here
yeah I'm sorry of course g4 doesn't work
as well because you opened up this
diagonal with this checkmate
so Queen uh five king g1 holding on
holding on for dear life yeah Tristan
Davis has it not Queen uh for hanging
the Queen instead Bishop takes e5 and
now Bishop h2 is threatened if King h1
Queen takes h3 wins if King f1 Queen
takes d3 wins
note we are getting this King one way or
another and there's no real way to block
this Bishop h2 threat the King can't
move out of the way we can't really
block the diagonal and so this is going
to simply be lost of course no matter
what white throws in the way we simply
capture it and no matter where the white
king goes we can check them or Bishop h2
will end the game
perhaps you give a check but after that
nothing else to be done
that's a game ender three checks black
is victorious all right good job on that
one guys you're getting the hang of it
you're getting the hang of it you gotta
start thinking a little bit differently
gonna start thinking a little bit
differently now of course it's time for
everybody's least favorite variant
antique chess there are some interesting
anti chess tactics though as the variant
is so forcing now what are the rules to
anti chess
well let me explain briefly you win a
game of anti chess if you lose all of
your pieces now how does that make any
sense
well captures are forced so if you can
capture a piece you absolutely
positively must capture a piece and with
this rule in effect you can kind of lead
your opponent on the string of captures
to try and get them to take all of your
pieces so let's jump into this puzzle
here now this is a pretty good initial
position there's only one legal move for
white so I suggest you play it to start
the tactic captures are forced as I said
so this is why it's only legal move so
white has to capture on d5 now black
only has one legal move he has to
capture back captures are forced and now
from here this is where the puzzle
begins wait to move
and win I'll give you hints one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven pieces for white however its mate
in ten believe it or not I should also
mention one more rule still mate is a
win for the side that cannot move I
don't know why it just is so the key to
this variant is figuring out a tricky
way to force your opponent to capture
all of your pieces so how can you do it
I should also note the king is not
special in anti chess
things like any other piece it bleeds
just the same it dies just the same so
don't be worried about the king here you
still want to get your king captured
okay hasta pata says be for it's a good
start be for is a good start
f4 is also a good start these are of
course your only two main candidate
moves you have to force your opponent to
keep taking your pieces now one of these
moves is better than the other one and
in order to see that you have to think a
little bit ahead so you have to think
well at 4 B 4 I know exactly what my
opponent is gonna play he's gonna
capture my piece and what do I play in
response to make sure he has to keep
taking my pieces so he has to take all
of them how can you force this to happen
Queen side castles has been suggested I
don't know about that one I don't know
about that one Queen side castles might
actually lose the game of course you're
not forcing your opponent to take
anything so oh it's also illegal here
feels like it should be legal maybe
castling just isn't a rule in a chess I
feel like it's not can't Castle nante
chess I just I don't know if you can but
you can't not in this puzzle
okay everybody is giving me one move
answers okay
all cars just given me a to move answer
that's better so it has Brian Clark
however they're both wrong so b4 Knight
takes b4 and then they had a pretty nice
idea they wanted to play York c1 and now
after Knight takes a two this lands
gonna have to take this rook on the next
turn except it won't because captures
are forced so white must take on c7 and
now the tables are turned and it is in
fact white who is on the back foot here
having to capture pieces with his rook
so not rooks e1 any other moves yes
Jonathan Harper but 9 h3 is illegal
captures are forced
captures are forced
so I'll give you a hint I'll give you a
hint
this night can't do it alone tonight he
can try but he can't do it alone
you need another black piece to come
into the fray to take all of your pieces
odd Karsch has it as does Terrell NEMA
and named enough name enough I'll go
with name enough rook b1 is the key move
now Knight takes a two is forced only
legal move rook takes b7 is forced only
legal move Bishop takes b7 is forced
only legal move and now what's the key
to end the tactic what do you do what do
you do there's a couple options here but
this is more or less the end of the game
provided white plays well
I'm just gonna assume the chat season of
course yet Tyrell has it it's g3 and now
the bishop has to take the rook on a1
which is undefended so you don't have to
take back and then you can kind of
string this Bishop along until the end
of time for example here efore Bishop
takes e4 Knight f3 Bishop takes f3 King
d1 Bishop takes d1 f3 Bishop takes f3 g
for Bishop takes g4 Bishop h3 Bishop
takes h3 stalemate winning the game for
white as you cannot move anymore and
that's a rule in ante chest for some
reason if you don't know that rule well
that's fine you can just play it
slightly different differently here with
let's say let's see you could do this
one first and then and then it's all the
same it's all the same all the pieces
come off the board one way or another
and you win the ante chess camp so
there's some ante chess tactics for you
alright I'll leave it up to the chat you
want to do more variant tactics I'm
gonna go back to boring old real chess
with boring tactics that you've seen a
million times oh look you'll find the
fork it's a double attack you checkmate
the King come on what do you want to do
what do you want to do you tell me you
tell me what do you want
antitrust seems like the most ridiculous
variant you must have not been here for
the racing Kings tactic but you know
I'll give you a close second give you a
close second there's waiting come on
guys make a decision what do you want in
the meantime I'm gonna throw up another
variant tactic while we wait for your
decision of course I'm talking about
horde chess who doesn't love a good game
of horde chess now this is one that the
stock fish here on lee chest is actually
unable to solve so we'll give you a okay
that's a lot of votes for boring real
chests boring chess boring chess real
and boring I see three votes for variant
atomic is okay we'll do one more variant
one and then switch over to real chess
so how about this this is a lot like
real chess it uses all the chess pieces
white still wins by checkmating a king's
so you got that going for you
check is legal so like you know most of
the rules okay
so this is of course hard chest white
wins by giving checkmate black wins by
taking all of the white pawns so the key
here is to figure out how you can force
a promotion for the white player white
promotes and hoard chests more than
likely he's he's gonna win the game so
let's see how can you force a promotion
with white what can you do how are there
two queens and Hort black must have
promoted black must have promoted got a
pawn all the way down to the end of the
board
find some way to promote here for white
though I have a nine sixty tactic I
don't know nine sixty tactic because
nine sixty tactics are chess tactics
chess is boring I want to play fun
variants like horde anatomic b7 King
takes b7 a king takes a 8 C 8 equals
Queen well Jacob you've hit upon the
nail the head of the nail you hit the
nail on the head with the idea the point
is if the King were the only piece that
were able to take this pawn the king
cannot stop all three pawns just can't
do it
can't stop him can't stop all three
alone however you have missed the fact
that this Queen one h1 can capture on b7
this would save the game for black got a
Dodge that one excuse me a six with the
idea of b7 not a bad idea either a six
if black plays some random move well
then we play b7 check nice move Queen
takes b7 is forced and now we have the
same tactic here me Queen takes and we
Queen unfortunately though for white and
there are more problems more problems to
be solved Asics very nice idea
unfortunately though black can save the
game with a very nice queen 5 2 F 3 now
against b7 we will still sacrifice a
queen but we'll have our backup Queen
there just in time so that is the crux
of this tactic can you distract these
black Queens for long enough to force a
promotion
can you distract one of these black
Queens away so that you're a killer idea
of a six can come onto the board hello
Ragnarok
eh-eh then a6l you're so close you've
hit upon the third problem in the
position we would love to play h8 when
Queen takes h8 would allow a six which
would win by force
check check check check
but of course unfortunately wait no wait
unfortunately it doesn't win by force
because after a six Black has the very
very nice move Bishop takes f7 when this
Queen is actually somehow helping b7
check Queen takes b7 8 x b7 and wait all
of a sudden this Queen is guarding the
back row and that's gonna be a win for
black so we need to block the
eighth-ranked and then distract the
Queen and then play a six and then
distract the King and then we can
promote our pawn so Aakash has finally
got it as the shadow Griffin and
karthick confit and quad reflects off' i
quad reflects off' i and oh my god
everybody everybody has it sook earth
has as well f8 Queen has to take h8
Queen has to take a six nothing to be
done to help this guy perhaps just punt
Queen takes pawn now check check and
check and white is doing quite well with
a queen on the board it's still gonna be
a game but this is definitely what white
wants to go for so there you go a nice
hoard tag tactic to round out our
variant tactics for the day now let's
switch over to some real chests over
here actually I have a few interesting
puzzles I don't know if you guys know
this about me but I used to go to
college I used to be on the University
of Illinois chess team which I was
briefly captain of before I moved back
to st. Louis and as captain of the chess
team I had to put together some tryouts
so today I want to see if you guys can
make the U of I chess team if you've got
what it takes if you can solve the
tactics that I gave to perspective U of
I students wanting to get onto the chess
team let's see if you can solve them
see if you can solve them so on the
board here I have a tactic from the
tryouts that I gave to some students
this one is on the easier side I'm gonna
say although it is still a bit tricky
its weight to move here weight to move
and win the game see what you can do
see if you guys have what it takes to
play chess for the University of
Illinois jacob t grapes is easy
he says easy sacrifice everything
GG resign always an option however not
good enough to make the U of I chess
team but will unreal chess tactics help
in real chess not necessarily but they
are fun and they will help you in not
real chess so I mean what's more
important here you you got your board
game I got mine Queen takes T seven I
mean it's the first move it's a first
move but it's not a full line if you had
written down Queen takes a 7 on your try
out paper and that was the end of the
line it gave you would have not made the
U of I chess team so who's got what it
takes
Tyrell has what it takes Queen e7 rook
d7 Queen txt 1767 Bishop f5 is a key
variation and I suppose it's good enough
for me of course Queen takes 7 now if
rook d7 the only move for white to win
the game is to take this guy and use
this Bishop to unveil this discovered
attack against the Queen if you don't
then of course you lose the game -
checkmate don't lose the game to
checkmate one more question for you guys
just for example if this were played how
do you save the game obviously you can
take this rook but now how do you stop
checkmate even after you win all this
material how do you stop the checkmate
here
how do you stop the checkmate one last
question to solve
move the bishop well moving the bishop
probably not gonna be enough actually if
you just move the bishop we'll take this
rook give this cheque maybe and at the
very least I'm gonna have a draw here
have to do better yeah everybody hasn't
now move of course is your key for you
just plant this rook in the way this
Bishop interfere with this coordination
and after takes takes takes the one
queen is not enough we are up a full
rook in a full the ship so there you go
it's a good first tactic good first
tactic so the way I would have scored
this if you were actually trying out for
the University of Illinois chess team
almost full marks if you give me this
line if you find out that maybe King the
ADA is actually worth considering when
the King ducking all the way back to a 7
and you give me that line as well well
congratulations you just made the team
all right on to the next puzzle here we
have a another one from the U of I
tryouts here it is once again black to
move this one a little bit easier I
think a little bit easier not the first
one was super tough but we're keeping it
simple for the for the most part keeping
it simple
so the main problem with this puzzle is
all of Wight's pieces are hanging you
have to figure out which one to take the
second problem with this puzzle is that
all of your pieces are hanging too so
you just have to find the best way the
best way to do it
check and when the Queen which check
York takes g7 has been suggested as well
winning a bishop
Queen takes Knight has been suggested so
you guys are hitting upon the major
points here Knight takes g3 is the check
with the knight that's been suggested
our car has still not specified which
check he wants to play Queen takes g5 93
93 all right so what's the problem with
rook g7 well rook g7 isn't a bad move at
all black isn't actually losing here the
problem is not actually winning either
we count the pieces black is in fact
going to be up a piece at the end of the
day here but the problem is we give this
check we play queen h5 this bishops
still hanging and we don't really have a
comfortable way to save it if for
example we play with Bishop a4 or
something kind of asking for a lot of
trouble with moves like Knight e4 you
know this Knights under pressure this f6
pawn this Bishop everything is kind of
falling apart so our takes g7 not
actually enough and of course Knight
takes g3 is not a good way to give up
the 9th cuz after H takes while you're
allowing this rooks to come into the
game as well and Bishop f6 might also
cause you some problems and things are
starting to look a little bit nasty here
starting to look a little bit nasty for
black despite being up the Queen
so of course Knight e3 check is what
must be played F takes c3 now you can
take the Queen and after Knight takes
back you win the bishop as well and you
are doing fantastic in this position
black is simply winning as for Queen
takes Knight which was suggested by a
few people of course your blundering
this rook on h8 and that is not gonna be
good so another tricky one here it's
kind of deceptively simple where you
know all of the white pieces are hanging
the goal of this tactic I'm looking for
people who don't stop at the first move
they might see rook g7 they might think
all right you sevens pretty good you
know I went a bishop I'm up a piece
seems pretty good but you look beyond
that you see a good move look for a
better one look for a better one
don't settle for going up a piece
especially when your king isn't such
danger go for more go for more
all right moving on this one is puzzle
number three this is white to move white
is in check and I will leave it at that
no hints on this one you'll have to
figure it out for yourself you're in
checks you got to do something when you
can win a queen win a queen not bad
advice from a harsh
White's move what can be done
Knight c3 I suggested before no thinking
is suggested so yeah this puzzle was
designed to see what they would do in a
forcing situation like this there's a
few things to take note of number one in
this Bishop's attacked this King is
attacked so you have to do something to
solve the problems now we have Bishop d2
suggested as well so there are three
candidate moves here now Knight c3 not a
bad move at all not a bad move at all
defense the bishop steps out a check so
once again this was a tactic asking you
to look a little bit deeper and really
examine all options even the less
intuitive ones
now from there perhaps they're a little
bit better at chess and they realized
that this Bishop cannot actually be
captured so if you block with Bishop d2
well what's this Queen takes bishop in
the 97 this is a check you're winning a
queen however Queen d8 could be played
here and after Queen d8 black is
maintaining all of his pieces so you
have to find even the less forcing
variations for black as well
Queen date a nice defensive move
captures are not forced in chess this is
not anti chess we had that earlier
captures not Forest Queen d8 saves the
game of course the move b4 is the way to
do it and now black simply has no good
responses you leave this Bishop well
developed on b4 here and the Queen can
not take the bishop due to the Czech
Queen d8 does not save the game due to
Bishop takes Knight and Knight takes b4
is illegal so b4 is the way to go it's
the most forcing and it leaves your
pieces in an active position it has a
winning response to all of blacks
replies not just some of blacks replies
so well done to you who found b4 okay
I'm gonna jump a little bit ahead here
so you can get some more difficult ones
and I'm actually going to present you a
different type of puzzle here I know
this is tactics time but perhaps you can
solve this quote-unquote positional
tactic it's a new term I'm pointing it's
a tactic for positional players
so if you're a positional player here
see if you can find the only good move
for black find the quote unquote tactic
to get yourself the good position
black to move
what can be done
so yeah Jacob T grave and Alkesh both
have the answer already
of course in this position black must
take this night on III and this is a
very common positional sacrifice that
you'll actually see in structures that
look somewhat like this where you have e
to an F to rook takes e3 is a great way
to break up these ponds and actually
give black a little bit of a nice
advantage here and this was a position
actually taken from one of my own games
that I had against Julian Coleco I
believe in a Friday action quads here so
just a little fun fact for you and the
Knight g4 of course puts pressure on
this newly weakened pawn you can defend
this pawn with something like Queen C 1
but things are going to go downhill for
you even let's say Queens C 3 a little
bit more of an active try but now simply
Bishop take C 2 is bad do two rook takes
d5 so not bishop take C two but instead
maybe Queen g5 putting more pressure on
e3 shoring up some weaknesses and
unpinning this this Bishop here so well
done to those of you who found Rick
takes e3 with the idea of Nigeria up
putting pressure on these weak pawns in
the center for white okay how about
another positional tactic for you guys
positional tactic here it's white to
move and find a nice maneuver white to
move and find a maneuver find your worst
piece and then find a maneuver to
improve it in this positional tactic
a key positional attack tactic
flip the board why would I flip the
board it's black to move black to move
and improve his worst peace night be
three is highly illegal it's black to
move
might be through the night c5 did I say
wait to move on accident something it's
black to move it's black smooth stop
playing mp3 it's white it's blacks turn
everybody's playing update did I say
wait it's black to move ah
Oh Tristan is upset
we made him over cook a steak we
distracted him with too much chess okay
I said white - I apologize is black
Timnath Harshal has an idea and he has a
pretty good idea as well I don't know if
I like the particular moves he chose to
play it of course
blacks worst piece here is gonna be this
knight on g6
and so I asked you to find a maneuver to
improve it which square looks like the
best place for this night it's gonna be
c4 he chose to do it this way I think I
would just slightly prefer to bring the
knight back to f8 no reason to really
interfere with this rooks access to to
e5 and blacks gonna play some moves he
can put this night all the way up on c5
if he wants but what's gonna happen is
we can actually take this piece off the
board if we ever so desire and from
there you know this pawn is gonna be
horribly weak
if you don't play Knight c5 for example
rook e1 well your day of reckoning is
coming my friend let's say Rick v1 or
something Knight c4 and this is going to
be a devastating advantage for black in
fact the engine gives around minus 2 and
a half almost minus 3 here with the best
move being Knight takes one after pawn
takes everything is it's just falling
apart these pieces are too strong for
for black so nice maneuver way to
improve your pieces noticing this Knight
is the piece that's not doing anything
for black and realizing you can move it
into c4 in due time well done well done
everybody
okay one more positional tactic one more
positional tactic for you guys it is
black to move
in this position black to move here and
play a positionally crushing move no not
in this puzzle other moves still
maintain an advantage for black but
there's a very distinct winning idea
that black can play do I teach daily I'm
on the stream almost daily
I teach Monday night classes and
Wednesday night classes be sure to tune
in tomorrow though when a better chess
player than I will be giving classes
that is of course international master
and orsa Derrick Shani
okay black to move and play positionally
crushing idea positionally crushing
ronbo suggested Bishop takes c3 Randi
suggests Knight e4 Jacob T grave once
Bishop takes c3 so try and give some
justification behind these moves some
justification Bishop g4 has also been
suggested but should take c3 then 94
Tyrell wants to take d4 with the knight
but he doesn't see the continuation what
do you think this is a tactics class
it's a positional tactic positional
tactic so most people I think actually
do have the right idea here everybody
wants to take on c3 and that is in fact
the key move here so you take on c3
Bishop takes c3 for example and now well
oh sorry that hangs this Punk
so pawn takes c3 and the idea is yes you
get this knight in to e4 but beyond that
black has a very clear winning plan here
that you can see there's drawn on with
arrows on the board and that's really a
powerful thing in chess if you see a
line that gives you a very clear very
direct winning plan you should almost
always go for it of course
white is not really doing anything in
the center he's lost control of efore
after this trade and so black now has
the go-ahead to simply push these pawns
up the board and these pawns are going
to be devastating to White's Queen side
and black is simply winning in this
position so well done if you found
Bishop takes c3 that is a very favorable
trade for black even more well done if
you spotted this plan of b5 and b4
this is the winning plan for black and
there's not much that I can really do to
stop it here so fun stuff positional
tactics we'll go back to tactical
tactics now just for fun tactical
tactics
this one is white to move see if you can
solve it and well you're doing that and
catching up with the stream I do want to
mention of course these are all
positions taking from the tryouts for
the U of I chess team that I ran a
couple years back now and so with those
last few puzzles if you at home are
playing along if you found the plans
then you're doing pretty well I gave
those positions and asked the the
potential team members to try and
justify their move try and give some
reason behind it so if you saw Bishop
takes c3 well done but it's not enough
try and find that winning plan of b5 b4
as well and then you're definitely
making the chess team I don't actually
have a personal YouTube channel I do
have a twitch channel considering making
youtube channel but I'm just too lazy if
you want to see me stream chess and
check me out on as the llama Lord but
that's beside the point
solve the tactic okay we see everybody
and their grandma wants to play the move
c3 Jakob T grave wants to take on f6
first and then play C 3 what's the
difference is the Illinois chess team
good I mean I was the captain of it so
no but no I'm just kidding they've got a
good group of a good group of chess
players up there they're not one of
these scholarship teams of course but a
lot of good chess players just
interested in playing the game for fun
so yeah of course if you play c3
immediately the difference is well I can
simply take this pawn but if you capture
first that's just a trapped piece out
there on b4 and the point I wanted to
get across with this puzzle was
identifying the misplaced pieces the
easily attacked pieces this net on b4
looks pretty lonely out there not a lot
of support from the rest of the black
camp and that's why that Knights gonna
be vulnerable to capture and after c3 it
is in fact simply attract piece I could
job on that one good job on that one now
we have a position here from a game
actually
that I believe was played between Andrea
Sein and Ilyas Mirren for those curious
and let's see if you can solve this
tactic from the game
I'll give you hints in the game and
rossion Andrea Austin I don't know to
say his name he found the tactic see if
you can play as well as that Grandmaster
see if you can do it
you can get a scholarship for playing
chess collegiate chess is actually kind
of taking off these past few years
there's a lot of st. Louis schools and
even Mizzou now in in the western part
of Missouri central somewhere
what's the st. Louis they have put
together some pretty strong chess teams
as well some Texas schools as well and
they have very excellent chess programs
that are well funded by the schools and
they get a lot of world-class players in
from all around the world to come play
chess so Knight takes d5 has been
suggested and Bishop takes e5 has been
suggested so these are really the two
key moves we have to consider and now
for the previous puzzles I was going a
little bit easy on you guys I was going
for the type of puzzle where you find
you know an interesting idea and there's
not too much calculation to do and
that's that's the end of the puzzle you
know you see the interesting idea and
that's kind of the end of the story
that's not the case with this puzzle and
this is the type of tactic that gets
messed up in tournament games you know
maybe the other type of types of tactics
are just like missed you know it's an
interesting idea you just didn't see it
in the game not what you can do this
type of tactic however is calculation
focused obviously there are two key
moves to calculate Bishop takes e5 and
Knight takes e5 and the question is do
you see the full line and do you see
which one is totally winning do you see
the full line
so the chairman's is still split the
chat room is still split so Bishop takes
e5 let's let's start with nine takes e5
actually 965 you guys have correctly
pointed out this ship takes C - isn't
that with knight takes g6 and then
Bishop takes d1 is met with a 97 check
and after King h8 rook takes d1 let's
count the pieces one Bishop one right -
one rook and two nights four very nice
material imbalance for white and it's
true that if black plays like this white
is winning however it's not really
forced is it not really forced so who
sees black to move and win after Knight
takes e5 who sees why 95 is wrong black
to move and win the game here
yeah of course Tristan has it Knight
takes d5 Bishop takes e5 the queen is
under attack as is the knight as is the
rook Queen e3 you're gonna get met with
Bishop takes c3 Queen takes c3 Bishop
takes D one rook takes D one and you
have lost the exchange
that's why calculation is the core of
chess it's the core of chess puzzles
court of just tactics you need to
calculate thoroughly to the end now
backing up that doesn't mean that you
clever folks out there who said Bishop
takes e5 are automatically right of
course if Bishop takes e5 well now what
if we eliminated we've eliminated after
you Knight takes e5 the option for black
to capture this Knight so Bishop takes
you two takes takes check up takes and
we are in fact winning this game with
two knights for the rook however this is
not the end of the story and also you
can simply take here perhaps this is a
bit simpler winning winning a full piece
with some funny I guess you're not
winning a piece Bishop g4 but then
things get a little bit funny with h3
and Knight takes h7 regardless though
White's winning in that line that's not
the end of the story Bishop takes e5
what if black plays something else
you're all discounting another key
option for black here
discounting another key option for black
in this position other than Bishop takes
e5
oh yeah Jacob T grave has anticipated my
question and has the answer for me
Bishop takes f3 is another important
option to consider for black G takes f 3
is going to be White's response opening
up this G file now if Bishop takes e5
well what do we have here we have a
simple pin of the Queen to the king
winning the game so well done to jacob t
grave he seems to have been on point
today solving a lot of these tactics so
the point of this tactic is to show you
guys you know it's not enough to find
the clever move some tactics you just
kind of have to buckle down calculate to
the ends and and get the job done so
that's what you have to do here in order
to solve this puzzle well just to give
out some some closing remarks here if I
were still in charge you would all be on
the U of I chess team you did great
today good job everybody except uh no
not accept anybody I'm just kidding
thank you all for joining me on this
episode of tactics time hopefully you
guys had fun solving some variant
tactics and then hopefully you had fun
quote-unquote trying out for the U of I
chess team you know at least we can
pretend thank you all for joining me be
sure to tune in tomorrow for more chess
action more fun my name is Caleb Denby
and I will see you next time
you